think back to where we started
[Music]
no it's just us
we need to end this war
this goes beyond loyalty
this is about survival
[Music]
we must fight together now or die
[Music]
our enemy doesn't tire
doesn't stop
they're coming
hey guys pete here finally got some more
season 8 footage
two short teaser trailers came out last
night at first they were just
recordings from the tv someone had done
with their phone but we got a couple
better versions finally
right before i started recording this
video we'll look at all the scenes here
that we didn't see from the first
trailer but these are more of an
extension of what we saw
than brand new trailers like there's not
a whole lot new here
definitely follows the same theme with a
little bit of extra
and some added voice over
the first big thing that everyone will
notice
i'm sure was that we see john and arya
together in a scene for the first time
since the first season it looks like
they're by the weirwood tree in
winterfell
although we can't see the pool so i'm
not sure exactly but there's snow on the
ground obviously
john has his standard brooding look on
his face
he's struggling with something and it
would appear that arya
is there to give him advice or at least
listen to him
the next additional clip that we see
here is
we had seen this photo of daenerys
in the original trailer but now we can
see it looks like jorah is behind her
we see him come out of the shadows there
we get an
aerial shot of winterfell with drogon
flying towards it this seems to be from
the same sequence whenever they are
arriving at the castle
and in both clips we saw this shot of
tyrion varus and davos looking up
and to me since this is juxtaposed with
all of the footage of the dragons flying
around
also the shot of sansa looking up it
seems to me that they are pulling the
fast one on us
many people have been talking about this
since the first trailer came out because
we got this footage
of drogon and rhaegal flying around in
different settings that perhaps they
were pulling a fast one and that they
didn't put
john on rhaegal and daenerys on drogon
i think this shot here kind of really
ties it up you know that they probably
are all looking at jon on a dragon
seeing him for the first time and in
this first teaser of the two
the other image that we see is john in
the crypts laying a candle
and it appears to me that he is by ned's
statue this could be the same as the
first trailer where we saw daenerys come
to john while he's there but
it's hard to tell from the shot that we
see here
we've all been sort of expecting the
crips will play some part in john
coming to terms with his true parentage
but i don't think there's anything
additional here to give us context as to
what he's doing right then
another shot that was new is this one
here that's from inside the walls of
winterfell we can see the battle is
going on people are running around on
the battlements
in the first couple of shots we see with
the troops in formation
with grey worm you can tell that there's
been an actual battle going on when we
see this you see smoke you see
what looks like flames lighting up the
horizon
behind the walls this looks a lot more
like the
period of time where we see brienne
jamie and pod
and arya all fighting on the battlements
another shot of the unsullied in
formation
this looks like pre-battle and that's
about it as far as new stuff in that
trailer
the voice over is broken up into
different parts
it starts out by saying think back to
where we started
when i first watched it i thought this
was all john this whole part
but the voice kind of cracks on the
think back to where we started and maybe
sam's voice that we hear
first i'm not 100 sure you guys can tell
me what you think about that
then we definitely hear john he says now
it's just us
we need to end this war and then we hear
jaime's voice
who says this goes beyond loyalty this
is about survival
the second teaser is the one that we
hear
tyrion's voice over on the big shot in
this one is
tyrion standing in winterfell in the
great hall
we can see sansa sitting at the table
with daenerys
to her side tyrion is addressing the
entire room we should imagine that the
other northern lords are in the room
there as well
tyrion just says we must fight together
now
or die then we hear john again in the
voice over he says
our enemy doesn't tire doesn't stop
they're coming
another new shot here is we see daenerys
standing in front of
a fire john is behind her they look to
be having a serious conversation but
there's nothing else to tell us about
what they're talking about
daenerys has a pretty spectacular
looking braid but beyond that
we can't see her face can't see what is
going on with her
we get a shot of barrack with his
flaming sword
in the heat of battle so we can
say for sure that he's made it to the
battle of winterfell
i can't say for a hundred percent but it
does look like this
is him fighting with the hound this is
the hound silhouette in the front here
it cuts to his face in the next scene
like i said it's not a hundred percent
but i think that that
is the hound coming to grips with his
fear of fire
i think we're gonna see him do something
heroic there
we have another shot of the unsolid here
that's a new one
there in formation again this is
probably before the battle begins
we see a shot of john that's similar to
what we've seen with the other
characters
here he swings longclaw the background
here
isn't glowing red like in some of the
other battle shots we see but i'm not
sure we can make any
conclusions from that there's a quick
shot
of cersei that's mixed in there that we
haven't seen yet
she's wearing her crown and her full
gear
it's basically just her turning towards
the camera
and we can't tell who else is in the
shot with her
there's another sequence of john running
which we saw in the first trailer the
original trailer
this is a little bit longer i think and
we do see the fire in the background
here
but i don't see anything new to give
away any hints as to what
is going on in that scene there's
another
cool looking shot of the unsolid the
helmets
kind of in silhouette and then there's a
longer sequence
of aria fighting which doesn't give away
much more but it's a little bit longer
and a little bit clearer than we saw on
the very first
so not a whole lot as far as new footage
i mean they're two thirty second teasers
but quite a few frames that we didn't
see in the very first full length
trailer
not much that is surprising i wouldn't
say
it's interesting to see sansa and
daenerys sitting at the table but i mean
that's pretty inevitable that that was
going to happen
tyrion being the voice of reason
certainly the most exciting thing
is seeing john and arya in a scene
together it's been a long time coming
still no shots of ghost that are
confirmed in this one
we don't see melisandre we don't see any
gray joys other than the same shots of
the boats that we saw
in the original trailer we still don't
see the dead here either
and i don't think that's surprising i
think they want to keep that as a big
reveal but
even when we brighten up these scenes
they didn't give us
much to show us actually what's
happening just that there's a battle
going on
like i said you can see the fire in the
background but
keep in mind that doesn't necessarily
mean that the dragons are involved at
this point because
they're fighting whites and fire is one
of the ways that you can kill
whites and from what we understand
there's going to be bonfires and things
like that
so can't really tell much as far as
whether the dragons are actually
involved we do have that same shot of
drogon but beyond that we don't see any
dragon fire and we certainly don't see
the night king
or the sirion and his blue flame
anywhere
but it's still pretty exciting so let me
know what you think
in the comments did you see anything
that i missed anything new
that comes to mind after you saw these
teasers that you didn't think about
from the first trailer like i said i was
kind of
caught up with that idea that they may
have not put
john and danny in i mean it's cgi in the
first place it's not like they
would be in the shot until they put that
together
that one shot of sansa is repeated in
all three
of the trailers that we've seen so far
and
that one is the one that whenever people
said she looks like
she's just seen something that really
makes you think that john's probably on
rhaegal there
i think now that we saw tyrion davos
and varys shot i mean it pretty much
confirmed wouldn't you say
i don't know all right well let me know
what you guys think in the comments
please like the video if you enjoyed it
i got some more problems videos coming
out this week so if you want to follow
along with that
you know what to do thanks for watching
i'll talk to you soon